millions of people
are now losing their jobs they're losing
everything
you know and and when you look at you
know the worst advice is go to school
get a job because in the information age
you know with
uber is not you don't you don't need to
be an uber driver because uber doesn't
need you
and the biggest one of the biggest
employers
are trucks so all these truck drivers
you know who are
in going across the country and all this
stuff
they don't need you you know they can
put something in there and
other artificial intelligence will drive
the truck for you
so you know you know the explaining with
drones you don't need
pilot the pilot in the marine corps
and i went to pensacola florida where i
was trained and they said we don't need
pilots anymore
but instead of these big rooms where a
drone pilot said they can fly a number
of drones
and they won't do that with the airlines
because i don't think too much guys
gonna climb
on board so hi this is your drone pilot
talking to you you know i'm in
atlanta and you're flying to chicago but
that's you know that's
the airline's a little different if if
airlines stay in business
don't go to school why would you go to
school to get deeply
under not find a job student loan debt's
the worst possible debt ever
because in 2009 barack obama
took the responsibility from student
loans away from the banks
and what barack and his team said to the
banks
give as many loans as you want because
they need
money is created out of debt so we need
students to get into debt so by saying
to the banks
lend as much money as you can we don't
care if the kid can't pay it back
you know just punish him for the rest of
punished he or she for the rest of her
life
but we'll give you the money back so the
u.s government
backs up the banks the treasury backs up
the banks
and and kids young people come out of
school
in debt for the rest of their lives
because money is only
created out of credit and debt and taxes
that's how that doesn't exist
so the last thing is you know prepare
for the brave new world
world war ii generation screwed me
because they gave us social security
which is
broke and medicare and the baby boom
generation scrooge too because they just
left this place a mess
you know but god gave me
this and i'm not really religious but
i'm saying
this is here it's your selfie the
problem is as you know there's no
financial education in school you're
thought to be an employee
so you really don't have the power the
brain power to use this thing here
so go to youtube and find the best
teachers on planet earth
for really low prices are free but learn
how to sync your brain to this
and you're out but if you're sitting at
home right now
you know playing watching netflix or
watching porno or whatever you guys do
playing games you're wasting this
that's the difference you have choice
right now
you can decide what you put between this
ear and this ear
see the crisis there's no crisis out
here
the only crisis in our this and this
here
and in your heart are you brave enough
it's a brave new world
so if you're going to do the same old
thing you're probably not going to make
it
that's the thing i was talking about is
richness into financial transformation
not education transformation is from
poor middle class to rich i i am a rich
man
but i have to think like a rich man i
didn't want job security
i didn't want a pension i didn't want
the government to take care of it i want
daddy to take care of it
the transformation is metamorphosis
metamorphosis is when a caterpillar
turns into a butterfly we all know the
story
the definition of metamorphosis is when
an immature
form turns into adult form
immature to adult in other words
metamorphosis
means grow up grow
up you know you don't want daddy to take
care of you buy me to take care of the
government or
bernie or whoever's going to take care
of you
be an entrepreneur you know the future
is very bright for entrepreneurs
it's horrible for employees because
artificial intelligence will start
taking more and more jobs
by 2030 up to 20 million manufacturing
jobs around the world could be replaced
by
robots that's all oxford economics uh a
two-year study from mckinsey global
institute indicated
that by 2030 intelligent agents and
robots
could replace 30 percent of the world's
current labor force and this one is the
crazy one
mckinsey estimates that automation will
displace 400
uh and eight up to 400 or between 400 to
800 million jobs by 2030
requiring uh as many as 375 million
people to switch job
categories entirely uh now what does
that mean for people right now
here listening you know a lot of people
think and i know that you are
a a son of immigrants and i am a son of
another immigrant a lot of people think
those
people come over here and take out jobs
but i haven't seen an immigrant at the
airport when i check into a kiosk or
when i go through
a toll and all the tollbooth clerks are
are are
no longer there i haven't talked to an
operator in
uh 15 years because of google and i
haven't talked to a travel agent because
of
orbits and travelocity and of course
uh tax uh agents i mean tax people who
file taxes you got turbo taxes and
things like that now
none of those are what people may call
immigrants or low end workers
so everybody is being replaced and at
the number one job
for males in this country is operating
heavy machinery in large trucks but if
those going to become like teslas and a
bunch of
automated uh you know um
vehicles what are people going to do
however i don't ever want to say don't
embrace technology because we can
thrive off of technology so what are
your thoughts andrew
well first let me say that uh that damon
john has been ahead of the curve on this
like he didn't come to it you know
yesterday i talked to him about it years
ago
and david was like yeah this is coming
and we need to help
people prepare uh so damon gave a blurb
from my book
uh new york times bestseller i'm trying
to be like damon here um and also
it's great it's a good book yeah and
also damon here
and i met at the white house uh because
we were both just trying to help
entrepreneurs
uh and i thought that technology
mowing down common jobs is something
that entrepreneurs needed to know about
and the one one of the reasons why david
and i know this is true is that we've
run companies and you know when you run
a company you're just trying to get
stuff done as efficiently as possible so
if someone comes to you with a tool
software robot whatever it is and you're
like all right let's do it
uh and and you know that at some point
that's gonna be
negative for people who might have
filled those jobs
uh so technology is accelerating right
now
we do need to not uh
not be well i mean i'm a little scared
of it i was gonna say like not
be anti technology or anti-progress
because a lot of this stuff
could be really helpful you know
especially in a time of pandemic when
frankly you kind of would prefer the
delivery person
not be a person you kind of prefer for
the car just to come and drop the stuff
off and then you like type it in you
know what maybe you prefer maybe you
prefer that
you know you can listen directly to me
and you because this technology allowed
people to listen directly to us and not
only be captured by the 50
cable stations and regular stations that
control the narrative due to the
advertisers and their political stance
you can listen to anybody you want
because of technology
yeah so this this um this curve though
it's rough and i'm gonna
like put it in two different ways so
everyone knows or most people know that
i ran for president saying we should
just start giving everyone money
um which now seems like common sense
because literally you have tens of
millions of americans who got sent home
like how are people going to provide for
themselves
so that is the public response and i'm
convinced that if we're going to get out
of this hole there needs to be a massive
government uh response like giving us
all money
you know job creation programs up the
wazoo like whatever
can be done in the public level um so to
the extent that you're a political type
and if you're not totally cool but if
you are like you want to bug your
congress
person and say hey you know putting
people putting money into people's hands
a good idea
like you know that's one thing i
personally think right now
is the time because they're literally
figuring out how to distribute
hundreds of billions of dollars and why
is it that these giant companies are
getting
sweetheart deals and the rest of us are
like hoping to get our 1200
stimulus check so that's number one but
on on a private level
uh you know you have to to try and
become geared towards the things that
the new marketplace demands
and one of the things that the new
marketplace demands is trying to project
value from further away
you know which is painful because
i i'm someone who likes to just like go
to someone talk to them meet them like
if you're a talented
uh you name it like hair
dresser yoga teacher personal trainer
like you know you're used to being in
front of people
um but i'm seeing what's happening even
in my own home and like i'm seeing my
kids teachers
learn to project their teaching through
a computer or through the phone
and i can tell that it's new for them
but that's the kind of adaptation
that more and more people need to make
because like it or not
the economy is not going to just going
to snap back to normal like a rubber
band
um we're going to be at this for a long
time it's going to affect us for a long
time
most people still sell quarantine right
i think after this
people's behaviors will change and
things people thinking about all things
will go back to normal well things will
never be normal normals out the window
that's why i see it
so you think about back then remember a
number of years ago
when target came into canada
right when they're spending 1.8 billion
dollars buying up all the leases
of sellers they spend a few they thought
they thought it's going to be super
successful
what they didn't account for is they
spend months renovating all the sellers
location
and during that time consumers
we're buying from other places
locally with tnt we have other
supermarkets
we have a walmart so after they open
guess what they don't go back
they've developed a new buying behavior
i see the virus
the coronavirus the crisis did the same
thing
so then you think about poor people's
people staying home
example people who always go to events
or they always fly to do business this
forces them to use
online tools such as zoom and now
they're like
me being so bad we get done without
traveling
that's cool right and suddenly students
are learning
oh maybe we could save more time this is
great
we don't have to go to school we can
still learn as much from
home from home right before maybe you've
never tried uber
delivery you've never tried ubereat
well something you try a couple times
hey ain't so bad it's pretty convenient
so that shifts consumers behavior so a
lot of money
opportunities would would flow online
right so before as you know everything i
do is pretty much everything is 100
internet-based and more and more so so
what my
prediction is after this is over
there would be two groups of people okay
the first group would be
finally they're like oh my god i like
finally we're free we could get out like
they wanted they now they want to go out
and spend money they want to go back to
the malls
yeah they want to travel so you i think
in a short period of time you see
entertainment uh traveling like to where
some certain industries would boom
you will see that however a lot of the
industries would change quite
drastically
let's say you own a restaurant and you
go through this hell
okay and you probably won't
conduct business the same way right
because you almost let's say even even
make it
but you almost went out of business
right now you're like okay do i need
this big of a place maybe i need to
downsize a bit
i'm if i'm still going to be in the
restaurant business maybe i would build
a smaller place
but more like almost like a i would say
like a
food factory that i'm actually supplying
lunches and dinners
tap into the uber network for delivery
yeah 100 shadow kitchen right and and in
malls
i think people would think about okay
how do we have
different types of things that bring
people in because people more and more
so this is just my prediction
that malls will turn into more
an experienced entertaining type complex
right
and the shops won't be as big chances
are
you look at china it's already happening
the shop is very small
because it's simply it's almost like a
presentation center
you go in you see what you like you try
it on
you kind of scan it gets shipped to you
you don't actually carry anything
right so then you don't need as much
square footage i think that would change
so that's the first group of people
the second group of people they would be
like oh my goodness
crisis i'm totally unprepared
hong kong this is exactly what happens
after the sars right
incident people still wear masks a big
chunk of people
a majority of people still wear masks
all these years
when they go out because it's a new hat
people are more concerned
right and i think you would see certain
industries like
insurance would be booming because
people are a little bit more fearful
like what would happen to my future
right
uh what would happen to me if something
happened to to me with my family would
be
taken care of so i think that would
happen too
so things i would say wouldn't be the
same it just wouldn't be the same and
people think oh it's going to be
go back to normal no it's not going to
go back to normal
and in events i could already see this
is maybe a little bit
further down in the future but i could
see that
let's say tracial business i could
already see someone would develop
something where it's almost like a vr
that you don't need to go but you're at
home you're walking
through the trade show and you're
interacting with the sales people
if you see something you like you press
and then already
ships a sample to you or send you more
information that you don't even need to
go
the whole thing is actually virtual it's
very there's no
menu the whole thing is done virtually
right and the vendors are done virtually
right and then you can have a lot of
space right i could see that happening
i could see traveling already you can
see a little bit that you have people
that maybe they're not comfortable they
don't feel safe to travel
but same thing with a vr we are still
early but later when it becomes more
realistic
that hey what if i have like a little
robot thing
that follows my direction and just go to
places that i want to see
i could see that happening too like this
it sounds so
like from a movie or something like that
but i do say they're happening
in the next probably five ten years
that's how i would see it so definitely
the money is online the opportunities
are online
[Music]
and for anyone like young people for
sure if you want more advice
wisdom guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the chronovirus situation
check out the video right there next to
me i hope you find it valuable
continue to believe and i'll see you
there let's just say you're in the real
estate business
let's just say you're under commercial
real estate